I'm going to start today doing something that
maybe you will find surprising, which is I'm
going to phrase something that the Trump administration
did, even if indirectly.
The CDC is run by Donald Trump's selection,
doctor Robert Redfield.
The CDC, under the guidance of Trump's pick,
put together a fantastic document about how
to open the economy safely.
Now, you might be wondering I don't know,
Dave, but I saw that guidance that Trump promoted.
It seems pretty stupid, actually.
It doesn't seem that good.
And you would be right.
I'm talking about a document that was suppressed
by the Trump administration and has only seen
the light of day because it's been leaked.
This is a guide to re-opening that's been
in the works for weeks.
It contains really good, specific, detailed
guidance for different types of businesses
and organizations, restaurants versus churches
versus child care.
It's detailed.
It's put together by professionals and it
was done by an agency run by a Trump selected
appointee.
It's all fantastic, except that the documents
were covered up by the Trump administration
to see that they never actually see the light
of day.
This is almost as big a scandal as Trump's
bungling of the medical side.
They have good guidance for how to reopen
the economy.
This is what we've been looking for.
Dr. Robert Redfield worked on this for weeks
at the CDC, showed it to doctors like Dr.
Bourke's and Dr. Foushee.
Redfield even approved it by email.
But it was this appeared never to be seen.
It's now been leaked to the Associated Press
by CDC staffers who did not have permission
to publish it.
They knew the right way to reopen.
The CDC put hundreds, thousands of total hours
into this, and they're just ignoring it because
the optics wouldn't be good.
Now, by the way, not I don't want to get off
track, but even the guidelines that the Trump
administration did put out about how to go
to Phase 1, almost all of the states that
have reopened have not actually achieved the
guidelines that supposedly you need to achieve
to go to Phase 1.
That's a different story.
The document that the CDC put together would
have saved lives.
There are all sorts of businesses that want
guidance for how to open correctly.
And the guidance is different in a restaurant
than it is in a church.
So, for example, they had a guide with advice
for restaurants and it includes lists of exactly
how bars should be cleaned.
Pay special attention to food contact surfaces
and how bathrooms at restaurants and bars
should be dealt with.
It addresses the issue of physical menus.
I've tweeted before the physical menu is a
cesspool of germs that should be eliminated
altogether.
It talks about continuing to use disposable
utensils, even for people who start to eat
in the restaurants.
This is really good stuff tailored specifically
for restaurants.
But Trump just wants things wide open.
So this guide was smothered and covered up.
It has different guidance for churches.
For example, actually tailored to churches,
for example.
Everybody over age 2 should wear a mask at
church.
Period.
Trump doesn't want that getting out there.
Put up signs all over the building, the church,
synagogue, mosque, whatever, so that people
see the social distancing guidelines wherever
they look.
It encourages video streaming or drive in
services, suspend a choir.
If your a community of faith has one because
people standing near each other singing is
a great way to spread droplets.
Singing spreads the more than talking.
These are really good specific rock recommendations
and it all went in the trash.
Now one other note, which is the cover up.
Trump's press secretary, Kelly McInerney or
McKenny said Friday that these guidelines
were not actually approved, but we have the
emails to prove that they are.
As early as April 10th, Dr. Redfield of the
CDC was sharing this document with Trump's
inner circle, includes Brooks and Foushee.
On April 24, he again emailed the same documents
to Bourke's and others and said, just look
it over so that we can publish it.
The CDC was good to go.
They had approved it and they were just waiting
for the Trump administration to give them
the go ahead, which never came.
And of course, the Trump administration insisted
via multiple emails, view. are not authorized
to publish this.
This is not OK to publish.
So this is where we really are getting to
kind of the crux of what we're dealing with
right now.
Trump handling this well from day one would
have saved lives.
I've talked about what should have been done.
Somewhere between March 5th and March 10th.
It's not this pretend game where I was never
going to shut it down.
On January twenty ninth one.
We had no cases or almost no, no.
We're not saying that, but we are talking
about March 5, a coordinated 50 state response
that would have saved a lot of people.
Now, a lot of people on the right don't seem
to care very much about that, but it would
have helped the economy as well.
It would have helped have to to prevent some
of the economic damage that we're now seeing.
If we had a coordinated 60 day 50 state stay
at home guideline starting on March 5, on
March 7, March 10.
It would be over by now.
We'd be past 60 days.
We would be reopening potentially with the
guidance of the CDC document, which was thrown
in the trash.
It's infuriating, but it's also tragic.
It's tragic in terms of the life lost and
in terms of the economy.
And it all could have been handled far differently
without having to go to these outrageous things
like no one shuts a country when you have
one case.
I agree.
But what about when you have 221 cases like
we did on March 5th?
That's a different conversation.
They don't want to have that conversation